remember it was under donald trump we
had 1.4 inflation we were energy
independent we were a net exporter of
energy our border was secure and safety
and security we had at home and abroad
as we were was respected as a country
and donald trump accomplished all of
that while simultaneously dealing with
conspiracy theories one hoax after
another one lie after another one phony
investigation after another now all of
it undone by joe biden in 18 short
months now president trump's successors
are chronicled in a new book by former
senior advisor and son-in-law jared
kushner he joins us now he's the author
of the book it's in bookstores all
around the country and of course
amazon.com breaking history a white
house memoir
you know the amazing thing um you're a
part of history most people will never
really truly understand
what life is really like in that house
and what goes on behind the scenes
there's no doubt about it that
any objective
observation of the trump presidency it
was a consequential presidency
and we see after 18 months what can
happen
when you abandon the policies that your
father-in-law instituted in this country
what was it about him what did you see
about him that made him that different
so first of all sean it's great to be
with you it was a great honor to serve
and president trump took the
responsibility
very seriously to fight for the american
people and keep his promises you were
speaking earlier about all the different
accomplishments he was able to have
economically those weren't an accident
it's been awful to watch the inflation
that's happened the rise in gas prices
but all that happened under the guise of
all the investigations and attacks and i
read extensively in the book it really
is everyone who's read it have said that
it's a very fast-paced read and that's
because i weave together all the efforts
to try to push forward on the different
policies while simultaneously dealing
with all these false investigations that
we had to fend off because even though
they were based on uh crazy accusations
from the beginning whether it was the
russia hoax or trying to you know get
trump or impeach him for trying to
investigate corruption in ukraine they
were serious accusations and we had to
take it and you know one story i tell in
the book too is how president trump
negotiated a deal between saudi arabia
and russia in order to save our oil and
gas industry which now the current
administration has hampered which could
be bringing down the price of gas in
this country very quickly if allowed to
and it was a really intense negotiation
but president trump got along with
people in the world he got along with
vladimir putin he got along with
president xi it didn't mean he didn't
have tough discussions with them but i
really go through the way that he dealt
with them which is how he kept the world
peaceful all the critics who again you
know that were lying about the trump
administration for four years they were
saying that if trump was elected he
would lead to world war three but we had
six peace deals during trump's time and
the world was a very very safe place so
i would go through all that extensively
in the book let me ask you this then
because he did it while being
investigated what three years on
trump-russia collusion that never
happened he did it during an impeachment
all this happened and then covet hit and
and that threw the world upside down how
did he do it
while simultaneously having to deal with
all that stress that probably would have
crushed a million other people
well if you would ask him that he would
say do i have a choice you know he was
elected he had a big responsibility and
uh and it was very very hard and we were
very grateful again i would you know be
at night i'd turn on your show and i
would you know see yourself greg jarrod
solomon uh you know sarah carter uh
going off and basically saying all this
stuff is debunked and then i flip over
to msnbc and i would see them saying
they're right on the heels they're about
to get these guys and i'm saying but we
didn't do anything and you know you
really had to just block that off and
just focus on the different things that
we wanted to do and president trump was
very focused one of the efforts that i
worked on that i detailed in the book
was the efforts in the middle east to
try to bring peace between israel and
the arab countries and that's something
that the conventional thinking was that
it would never happen but president
trump was an outsider he brought a
businessman's approach to washington
businessmen are results driven unlike
politicians who generally wanted just to
process
there are some great politicians too but
i write about how an outsider with
without a lot of political experience uh
and a team came in and were able to
achieve results that the political uh
career people were not able to achieve
and so the book really goes through the
detail
all right two-part question
one is speculation on your part maybe
you do know something that we don't know
do you think he's going to run
and when you factor in all the your
family went through and we're talking
about don jr and eric and laura and
ivanka and the whole family when you
factor all of that in do you want him to
would you want to go through that again
well it still continues for a lot of the
family
so first of all i i don't want to speak
for him and obviously he is very
bothered by what he's seeing happen in
the country he did a great job keeping
our economy strong keeping our world
safe
and really fighting for american
industry and i think that he knows that
he could fix it very quickly but it is a
big toll again he's constantly under
siege it was a big toll on on the entire
family but i think that the way we all
viewed it is that the cost of of service
and all the attacks and uh what was was
was very small relative to the impact
that
president trump and his administration
were able to make for on so many people
and their families you know one thing we
worked on that you were very supportive
was our criminal justice reform where we
were helping people who made mistakes in
their lives re-enter society with
training and job skills so that they
don't commit crimes in the future all
those people are given a new lease on
life all the pardons the alice marie
johnson's that president trump were able
to give help give second chances to that
was incredible work which you know when
you think about that it really you know
puts all the pain and stuff in context
and so for me writing the book it i
always like to look forwards not
backwards but it really was a reminder
of that brutal first year when we had a
lot of different people trying to find
their way in the white house again we
were being accused of colluding with
russia which was a crazy notion i mean i
would look at it and say you know most
days i couldn't collude on the campaign
with donald and we could include with
our field office in iowa yet they were
saying we pulled off this whole
elaborate scheme
but the same people who are pushing that
false narrative are the same people who
are continuously attacking president
trump and a lot of the republican party
who are fighting just to you know fight
for the middle class and in order to
give them jobs and give them opportunity
and to keep our country safe
it's called breaking history bookstores
everywhere amazon.com if you want to
sign copy jaredkushnerbooks.com
uh jared appreciate you being with us
and uh i learned a lot and i thought i
knew a lot about what was going on and
there was a lot i didn't know that was
going on thanks for being with us hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else